il suo ha eletto oggi nuova coppietta
sbagliato challenge abbiamo i palloncini
a forma di animali io faccio il gatto il
ricettivo a me sembra una tigre ha
veramente può essere oggi quesito perché
dovere in più poiché i mali sono
sicuramente lui si sbagliava s'illumina
evitare se sbagli e castori gioca allora
come sempre sceglierà la ruota in
consiglio che dovremmo copiare abbiamo
fa le nostre bacinelle così evitiamo di
va in piazza per imbrattare i muri con
la volta prima di intervenire
rapidamente dei miei firma copie per il
nostro bellissimo libro ecco è stupendo
dai colori allora se sono le date del
film a coppie è un'occasione unica per
incontrarsi perché non so vedremo in
italia
[Musica]
segnatevi la libreria e che vi è el
orario e ovviamente stanchi come
funziona allora se comprate libero nella
libreria del firma copie vi daranno un
passo per fare una fila prima però se
l'avete gioco prato sua mano da qualche
altra parte
potete comunque partecipare solo che
farete la fila dopo banali ben fatta di
firmerò comunque il libro che non vi
preoccupate se partecipare e quindi vi
aspettiamo non vediamo l'ora di vedere
lasciato bellezze volete vedere altre
challenges live con conseguente si può
ricchezza da inzuppare con la ruota le
più belle piacere un paesino e andremo
ad eliminarle fece mancano 5 siamo stati
più contenti ma allora cosa per vedere
chi vai carta forbici ha fatto tanto ma
il mio ci capita stiamo male quindi
invitare deve scegliere il palloncino
per me no magari troppo casa sempreverde
nomi ma anche questo secolo più grande
sito
presto quindi esser palloncino per sim
che è una tigre
secondo voi lo poniamo animal health con
due ottimi secondo te che rimane
comunque all'orecchio natale non puoi
bernardo tigrotto competenti fisso aiuto
andare gli occhiali protetti inizio
addio caro giangreco gardani su carletto
[Musica]
sulla cosa sulla penna cioè fate voi non
potete vedere maschi finestra sul
cavalletto e sulla luce e qualche non è
colpa mia
l'attesa è persa per sempre anche la
luce
[Musica]
abbiamo iniziato bene il gruppo alla
fine il telefono delle palline rosa per
una proveniente dal muro essendo
malissimo che esattamente prodi
dell'uomo unità altre norme molto bene
ma ci siamo dimenticati e che io
esistono timorosa elio celeste e come
dei propri che video potrete portare qua
metterlo poi il sondaggio servizio si
prova
[Musica]
questa volta non è ritirato lavorato
veramente volevo attaccare la scrittrice
pone
[Musica]
bianco bianca con glitter rosa possibile
l'inter domani arriva dal suo braccio
con bianca con di trini viola
io invece ho con la bianca con blu e
palline rosa finora sembra più bello il
mio ma vedremo vedremo se mancano ancora
tantissimi animaletti numero 9 vedo un
rumore
abbiamo un coniglietto che il casinò ma
la forza ci sono e un coniglietto con la
pancia gratta e vinci un colore detto mi
raccomando stai attento a non sporcare
la partita si passa tra le più a
coloriamo tutto in non era pazzo figlio
aiuto lasciano qualcosa anch'io
ma messi là dietro
[Musica]
cosa ha spinto purtroppo li ha mai visti
hanno preso l'impatto segue colore
quando in cuor loro che fortuna però
diciamo back l'infarto coniglietto
perché non domenica non importa se
funziona neanche questa volta per parte
quello studiato però magari mischia che
mima le abbiamo la rosa del mondo
animale fosse morto per un orso rota
questo è un tipo coniglio tipo di m
quanto in quello di cemento ma le carote
basta mi quello con il normale no alla
ricchezza o del non fare calcoli
scrivete voi i commenti numero 8 secondo
voi che rimane decisamente non coniglio
[Musica]
non è esplosa di questo punto non certo
dall'orecchio con il giallo giallo
imiteranno storicamente
bellissimo bella però aspettano mia
stanza certe madri mentre a detta
l'ultima parola del mattino voglio dire
niente ma che poi capiterà sicuramente
non poi vediamo pure diventa colore
vincitore però forse troppo poco questo
colore abbia colorarlo java meglio
quindi vediamo se ti capita qualche
altro un animaletto con un colore dentro
per stato chiarissimo
mi piace di evidenziatore leggero chiaro
con le colleghe slitta cosa ne dite di
sì perché se non all'inizio dell'iter
mettiamo il mio invece chiaro che è
enorme
ho già il pot che se la schiuma da barba
potrebbe diventare un bellissimo club
qui speriamo grazie al racchiuda barba a
meno che quello blu non fosse colla ma
solo colorante in più adesso ma molto
insieme ad altri che sono colorate con
colla mi devo sperare finita con la
definiti non essere un bel niente
[Musica]
abbiamo aperto sempre pronti grotto mati
grave poiché animale e penso che sia se
pronti brotto verde il maresca perde non
so se sia una cosa positiva con prof
janko dentro mezzi ma questo e ha inizio
e figli dobbiamo vincere bene
[Musica]
[Risate]
aiuto
[Musica]
ma che cos'è a chi mormora maira
finissimo per pratici
[Musica]
oddio questo è il misterioso il
coniglietto sente insicura sempre
mandare i lavori di là va bene sconto
del 20 l'oggetto ora prepariamoci al
rimpatrio
[Musica]
allora è fortunato potrebbe diventare a
due orsi nei live che siano cambiate
trasparente vediamo un po mischia bello
per essa diventa un bel prossimo dipende
anche da questi capitato un bel grossi
bianco riflessi gioia perché ti cambi di
qualche però riflessi gialli
fosforescenti che i colori scuri che ti
capiti il rosa come mio team perché tu
ce l'hai con me colorato dominio ora
invece qua a un'altra montagna di
schiuma da barba incredibile questa
volta
però insomma stanchi si incolla con la
sottostima per niente questa comunque il
mio slime vaschetta d'acqua decisamente
la repentina una ricchezza d'acqua in
modo certo tutto è altro che quello è il
numero 77 hanno detto che si muove
grazie che mi dedicherò vera chicca bdm
[Musica]
brano ed è e non volete quello animale
che non sappiamo che rimane è vero un
giorno sarà un leocorno vacanza con due
volte scrivetemi come una bestia
io tutto
[Musica]
momento era una protezione allora siamo
pronti a l'impatto che il sito
bellissimo viola e se la colla
trasparente il gruppo cultura così via
mi piace tanto piace per me non so che
colore sia la penserebbe grigia perché
sono accorto fatto hanno lasciato la
forza
se il collaudo un po di cose che si è
incollato la cassa vabbè non dare le mie
mani dalla mia pulitissima perché perché
io un punto tutto sul tavolo perché
altezza è scappato ho paura ma vediamo
[Musica]
ma perché tengo ma la bocca chiusa ma
sembra colla si sa che non a colla verdi
forse ti conviene di più bella perché
pure sei una colla là dentro
io vedo sono 80 le sta potrebbe essere
colti potrebbe tornare utile
sei sicura convocati la scalata
cosa devo fare ma è già certo prendetevi
servirebbe un pd cosa e questo non mi
sembra con la valigia scelto no decinaia
come decide di tutto bisogna scegliere
bene che cosa però un aspetto un po
strano tra pasteris temi ed altre novità
né quando tengo io per me si vieta di
gioia
per questa volta provo affidarmi vicino
mite e ti do il 4 questo mi sembra che
ha un colore che mi piace
veniamo poi grazie grazie a verde no non
mi sembra
ho paura
si no quello che volevo convalidato nov
e iniziato lo scorso mese abbiamo
invertiti guarda le location lo sly nota
ne ha da artisti dosi è sicuramente
bello perché quell'anno metallizzato e
bellissimo ha bisogno io ci ho ricattato
la scheda detto che tu hai bisogno di
più colti in free volevo questo qui è
già la bolla cielo ce l'hai quindi che
sia favorito c'è tanta stima la barba
vediamo il mancato stephen m siamo
pronti a un po come diventa però quel
colore per cento ma io con la bianca con
la trasparente quindi potrebbe venire un
bellissimo grossi di lui abbiamo vissuto
ce l'ho io devo stare se non solo
attento ad attivarlo bene infatti
potrete ancora rovinarlo effettivamente
di nuovo volante se andiamo a mischiare
il mio viola con il blu e vediamo che
colore di vento è stranissimo bravo però
che non diventi grigio poi dipendente
dal quale altro colori summit era dopo
reti a un po almeno ho avuto il gol
quella è la cosa positiva un po di colla
così sono sicura che lo sna riuscirò
però non so particolare questo slancio
berlino il colore diverso a stuprarla
speriamo per volta l'accordo dipende
cosa uscirà nell'ultimo palloncino che
qui
rimasto il palloncino per me il
palloncino inquietante tra l'altro che
animale questo fosse un cazzo perché
avere chi a punta piatta invece sembri
tipo un orsetto le orecchie a punta e
detti quindi io penso che sia un caldo o
una volta una volta il gatto la vediamo
finalmente cosa si sente troppo vicini
che ha destinato a te casa va diviso
andata comunità vediamo le dovute
precauzioni aiuto
a questo bellissimo colore verde non si
può staccare la concorrenza quindi può
essere se è bellissimo cosa no veramente
guarda visto lasciate ingannare da te la
strega cattiva
eccolo dove il bisogno di più col primo
articolo su certi che i colori mentre
adesso
beh io spero che verde acqua verde di
celeste come diventa bere acqua grigio
ma c'è non ci posso credere che mi sono
fatta ingannare e guardate il mare
spero che non diventi comair de la
maledizione del piano coloriamo la città
perfetta per colpo a digitare la
maledizione del perde ha colpito ancora
dai non celestino chiaro al momento ma
perché non si sa ancora bene perché il
verde in genere beach sempre in mente
riccio sempre il bello gente generosa ma
è bello rosa e al momento il viola il
mio secondo me aiuto tanto un po sta
diventando tipo grigio fanta le
considero se diventa dirige lo sarà
sicuramente bellissimo the radio
indovina chi vincerà non vedo l'ora di
vedere la consistenza come diventa del
mio giro non vedo l'ora di vedere in
molti ora andiamo ad altri 32 euro
ok ragazzi questa volta ci siamo
superati con islam sono usciti entrambi
bellissimi e la cosa come che sono
usciti tutti del team un po dal colore
del vento
allora questo lo bianco sito mai uscito
un mega flop separate supporto è
bellissimo tutto comunque è un sito
superflash.it fortunatamente in verde
non l'ha avuta vinta questa volta ed è
rimasto celeste si è schiarito da tempo
che meraviglia ragazzi e filo d'oro è un
po lucido anche perché c'é la punto la
palla bianca per assicura così tanta
schiuma da barba è uscito un super flop
enorme sitp un po
[Musica]
quindi adesso il castello sly un buffo
mi piace tantissimo pochissimo di passo
perché blocchi vediamo se evitare riesci
a battermi questa volta di vedere il
commento botte da 110 per aspetto e
persone mr
vediamo un po vai il team ed allora ecco
il mio è un bellissimo e con l'area
dello stretto super super buco
allungabile è abbastanza su afoso e più
grossi in pochettino grosse si è che va
ancora un po per farlo su dati possibile
mi aspettavo
incredibile che stanno imparando fare un
pò king dove vedere la sua faccia felice
e soddisfatta con le le cose cambiare
[Musica]
niente
questo mio io sono davvero contento
perché mi era mai uscito uno strano così
bello è la prima volta esce così
stupendo amerindia kalinka roso anche su
irlanda servizio questa volta affitto di
nome sarah si daranno l'ora ma poi non
vogliamo premiarmi per come ho parlato a
fare più pop effettivamente sempre sto
facendo la pizza però va bene
[Musica]
ma sono bellissimi tutti e due
il mio è molto più grande e profondo per
il mio piccolino ma super bellissimo ma
che belli che sono non ci posso credere
che se sono usciti così bene cosa nel
challenge stanno per avvicinarsi un po
troppo cosa come curiosità proprio del
nostro team ha opposto
allora vediamo è visto che blocco a te
molto è un po rigido inizio bello sono
stato il suo allora ragazzi io vito
secondo voi a me piace tantissimo questo
slancio ma che è il mio
[Musica]
allora mi lascio qui successo in cui
potete votare se ha vinto anita timbrata
musicale team azzurro riguarda la
mettiamo si imposta contro slime i
nostri colori opposti d'art moderne
ascolto ai commenti che mi lasciano di
attivato i piani di mettere poi così
più bravo ora vi lasciamo con 49 su cui
di carmela nostra speciale con la ruota
altri divertenti non succede in gestione
le nostre reazioni cliccate su quella
che preferite
buona visione ciao